this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the ramsey show where debt is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
anthony o'neill number one best-selling
author and ramsey personality is my
co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money
this is a show about you and turns out
you people are pretty entertaining
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five dustin is in dunkirk
maryland hi dustin welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dave how are you anthony how are you
guys better than we deserve sir how can
we help
hey i'm a first newsletter so if i'm on
my words of mumble just so uh let me
push through
um i currently
um owe twenty thousand dollars on a uh
my last loan and i'll be debt free
carmax
today offered me 26 000
i love my truck but i want to be
debt-free more um
my parents and my friends are like keep
the truck don't worry about the debt
but i want to call you guys and get your
opinion
wow how old are you um
37 sir what's your household income
uh 117 000
okay and your only debt is 20 000 on
this truck
yeah yes sir and you love it and you
love the truck
yes but i want to be debt free oh i want
you to be debt-free so i disagree with
your family or whoever it is that says
don't worry about the debt anthony we
worry about today absolutely i i do
worry about the debt but you've got a
great income and you love this truck
won't you reach over and knock it out in
the next few months
yeah absolutely because here's my fear
you'll sell the truck
go buy you a car for six thousand
dollars and you won't be happy and and i
think
and you'll buy another truck in two
years exactly you know so if you have
the money
twenty thousand dollars with 117 k
grosses mean you're bringing about 85
as a single person right you can have
this thing paid off
yeah minimum uh every two weeks uh but
i guess my thing is right now i'm i'm
home in maryland so that's why i gave
dunkirk but i live in new york
okay but how fast how fast can you pay
it off yeah
um because of my line of work i cannot
get a side uh
a side job you don't need
uh i could pay it off by the end of the
year
yeah yeah that's what i was thinking i
mean 10 months
yeah that's 2 000 bucks a month you
ought to be able to do that you probably
will actually do it a little bit faster
because you hate that
yeah yes yeah i mean you'll probably go
on beans and rice a little deeper it
sounds like you're single
yes okay which means you don't have
talking by end of this no
you just go on beans and rice you can
just say i now have
no life until the truck is paid because
i love this truck enough i'm gonna give
up lifestyle
for eight to ten months to be able to
keep it and
knock it out and next time we get ready
to do something like this we'll just
save up and pay for it because you're
committed to no debt right yeah uh i
i guess sir so so you're saying i would
keep it if i since you like it
yes yeah i drove my raptor this morning
i like it enough
to give up 10 months of lifestyle to get
to keep it
yeah and lifestyle destiny i'm i'm a
challenge dave on two thousand i'm gonna
stretch you to three thousand dollars a
month
you know because i think that hearing as
a single person
the only expensive thing you should have
is your rent and so everything else bro
you're eating at home
you're not going out on dating yeah
anthony i'm
i'm cashflow in college oh oh okay
that's 1840 every two months but i get
reimbursed
through my agency so it's i retract that
there sorry dude
there's an added piece of mathematics
yeah okay i'm with you
yeah so hey man i'm proud of you you're
doing good stuff
if you if you want to sell your truck
you can yeah but i think within 24
months you'll be back into a truck
very similar to that that you pay cash
for and i wouldn't go through all that
gyration to end up in the same place
three years from now yeah i agree
and so far i paid all 60 grand since
october 2019
and i just started back my psp because
it's been almost two years
you started back your tsp yes sir
because it's been almost two
to two years and you said uh
if you can't pay your debt off within
two years start it back up
okay two no two to three years two to
three years if you're gonna do this i'd
stop the tsp for eight more months but
i mean it's not you're you're fine
you're gonna be all right because here's
the thing about you
you've got two or three things that are
going on one is uh you're teachable
two is uh you've decided to not borrow
the money anymore yeah and
three is you're being very intentional
and thoughtful about every move with
money
yes you're not um you know you're not
wandering around there's not a bunch of
chaos in your life you're not making
this up as you go you're not being
impulsive
you're being very intentional
intentionality i mean when we do stupid
stuff
all of us is when we're just not paying
attention yes absolutely
but when you are saying i have a goal
and is this congruent with my goal
no that i'm not doing it when you have
that boundary in your life that's not
aligned to your goal
and not aligned to where i want to be
when i grow up so to speak then
that gives you the ability to go kill it
yeah and absolutely dave and here's the
thing i want people to hear dave and i
are not saying yes we like car payments
what we're saying is there's two things
one is less than 50
of his income and he can pay it off
within the next two years
and so because of those two things there
it's like okay you can you can keep it
if you want to
but if you wanted to sell it he could
but he likes a car and he'll be right
back there in two years yeah
it's not it's not gonna be a uh if this
was gonna be a seven year thing or
something and this knocked off half of
it yeah i would do it
but it's you've got everything done and
i would i would temporarily stop your
tsp again i'd tighten that budget as
tight as you can do it
and that eight to ten month mark by the
end of the year that's where i would be
with this so
well done sir yeah very well done hey
let's talk about it though he's cash
flow in college
that's neat i mean i was like don't drop
by that yeah don't let's not miss that
one america he's not making any excuses
he is being intentional he doesn't rack
up any more debt he's ready to get out
of debt
i love that man keep that going you know
there's something to
that i mean it's um
it sounds kind of mean and i guess it is
but
the amount of whining that is going on
in our culture
the wussification of america the amount
of whining that people are making
excuses
yes and blaming some other outside
force for their inability to get up off
their assumptions and go do something
correct
is astronomical it's unprecedented
the level of whining yeah are there real
barriers
you betcha absolutely you betcha yes
yeah
and uh you know are are there real
things that are out there
yeah are they keeping you from winning
not nearly as much as your belief that
you can't win no you know what dave i
say this the greatest enemy to our
success
is our excuse yeah that's it it's it's
not it's not the government it's not
uh the things out there are there real
issues out there that could prevent some
moving forward absolutely but the
greatest enemy to anthony o'neill's
succeeding
is myself and my excuses yeah cause i
take
one little possible excuse and i i give
it the weight of a thousand pounds
and it was a two pound weight right
right okay so
shut up yeah you know i mean that's what
i have to tell my little drama queen
self
you know shut up stop your freaking
whining
roll up your sleeves get up like he's
doing yeah
leave the cave kill something and drag
it home absolutely you know this is up
to you your destiny is
more in your control than it is in
control of the democrats
or the republicans or whatever thing you
want to watch on the stupid news
turn off the news shut up and go make
you a life
i mean that is really the formula and
that's what this guy's doing and that's
how i know he's going to win we call it
intentionality but that's what it is
he's just not going to accept anything
except winning
this is the ramsay show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
well it has been a stressful 12
months around the world and we've all
gained a new appreciation for lots of
different
professions and enhanced appreciation
one of them is teachers yes sir
and our team is celebrating them with
all the hard work and dedication that
they give out every day with our teacher
appreciation giveaway
sponsored by mint mobile the affordable
premium
wireless provider i don't miss out on a
chance to win
some awesome cash prizes you teachers
like 5 000 cash will be given to one
teacher
there is no purchase necessary of course
and to go to if you're a teacher go to
ramseysolutions.com
teacher and enter today if you're not a
teacher let someone that you know that
is a teacher
uh benefit from the chance to register
for that
so how many teachers can you count
over the years anthony that changed the
trajectory of your life i can count
about
five or six in k through 12. yeah
and i can remember distinctly some of
them that mailed it in yeah
but some of them that were complete life
changers ray clan denny was the one that
really changed my life tremendously
um then i can count about maybe three or
four of them
that really played a huge role but miss
clintoni
uh dave she literally just sat me down
she said if you don't change your life
i'm going to have to expel you and i
said i'm going to change
and she literally walked through that
whole process with me
what were you doing just just i was a
knucklehead kid i just always talked
back to teachers you had a mouth yes sir
which is very good it pays me a lot of
money today
it turned out that your greatest
weakness is your greatest dream
exactly and she thanks to her she
harnessed that
uh that thoroughbred and uh you learned
to run in the lane absolutely dave she
was the one who introduced me to uh to
the nfl the national forensics league
which was debating
oh she was like since she would love to
argue she said go be a debater yeah do
it do it actually in a pro
in a productive way instead of just
interrupting my dad gum class
exactly yeah i wonder how many of our
ramsey personalities were the kid that
interrupted the class
because i definitely was that i got in
trouble for talking oh more
than i did not doing homework more than
i did anything else man listen
talking up and speaking up and running
my mouth and always having an opinion
even when it was something stupid always
cracking a joke
yes trying to get the whole class to
shut down laughing yes i mean i got into
more
i hadn't even thought about that dave i
and looking at you i can completely
believe you did that oh dave all day
long
i believe that makes no sense
[Laughter]
[Music]
she was like excuse me and i'm like i'm
sorry
what do you got tourette's right i mean
and it worked dave because you know in
debating you're supposed to cut the
other person off when you're arguing in
their stance it was just
and i fell in love with it and she
literally taught me how to use
my gift in the right way i wonder how
many of our ramsey personalities
did forensics i've never asked
actually did speaking i did the speaking
um stuff
uh up through about freshman year by the
time i got up in high school i was too
cool for it
but in junior high man i was way into it
i loved it in high school
wow that was so interesting i bet i bet
ken coleman did that
oh i'm sure he did it yeah that would
just be
no way christy wright probably did it
too because she loves to argue and john
deloney got in trouble for talking we do
know this for sure
and we don't even have to ask all the
personalities
there's no question this is funny i
can't wait yeah
so teachers change your life we've
established that and
we have a high school and junior high
school middle school curriculum called
foundations in personal finance that has
taught been taught in 48
of the high schools in america we've had
millions and millions of students go
through it over the years
and we have wonderful teachers of course
that teach that curriculum so as we're
honoring teachers
this month we're actually pulling up
some of those teachers that are life
changers
on the line and chris rusher is one such
teacher
in williamstown west virginia at
williamstown high school
hey chris how are you hey dave anthony
how are you guys
great man thank you for what you do
brother so tell us about your school
and about teaching personal finance in
foundations and personal finance
i'd be glad to we have the we're in the
best school system in west virginia and
wood county schools and we have
the best school in wood county schools
and
one of the mainstays of our curriculum
here in business education which is
career and technical education
base is doing foundations and personal
finance
i've been associated with it for the
last six years
and it is phenomenal it changes people's
lives just like y'all were just talking
about
and it's critical it's critical that we
get young people engaged in things that
are actually going to matter in their
lives
we need to get them at this age started
on the right path so that they can
control their financial futures they can
invest they can build wealth and give
they can be ready for the future
so that they can go make an impact it's
just a critical thing
and fortunately here at williamstown
high school we're able to
do this curriculum and my students uh
put them up against anybody
that's cool so is this a this sounded
like you may have
a a group of kids that are preparing for
uh votec as well
well you can uh cte is careertech
education and there's a whole world of
it
you'd have you know construction
agriculture auto mechanics
nursing you can have all of those things
combined and you can do the
business curriculum in a tech center
which we have here
which is phenomenal as well and then at
the high school
where you you have a lot of kids that
don't go to votec and so we have a whole
business program
and one of the principal foundations is
personal finance
wow we want kids in there in ninth or
tenth grade
so in either either case whether they're
heading to a four-year school or heading
into a vo-tech they're getting the
personal finance foundation laid under
them which is just amazing
very cool so chris let me ask you this
question what is one thing that you that
you're seeing that's resonating well
with your students
uh where you're teaching uh this
curriculum
well i know we got to be brief on the
program but the resonating
factor the a number one thing is the
reality
of the condition of life and society
hits them
really hard when they start looking at
personal finance
one of the keys that we do is we don't
we don't power
you know sugar coat things we don't give
them the mamby pamby
uh jack wagon excuse train we tell them
look in real life you've got to perform
and if you don't perform it's you on the
line you are your own business
and i have four rules in my class
one is to make an impact and if they're
gonna
make an impact in their family
communities churches schools
uh in the society in general
you've got to be solid financially to do
that you might want to donate 20 million
dollars to your favorite charity but you
can't if you're not making a profit
come on and if you're not managing the
money we also talk about deadlines
and we talk about expectations in the
workplace here's the reality guys and
you guys know this but
the reality is this unless you want to
achieve the greatness of living in your
folks basement for the rest of your life
you've got to do something amazing and
you've got to take
life and take charge of it
and if you start at the high school age
the biggest impact is this they don't
need to make the financial mistakes that
i made
until i got smart in my 30s and still i
started listening to
you know dave ramsey until we made a
difference in our lives
uh i'll just throw in real quick my wife
and i just paid cash for our new home
this summer yeah
hey i want this guy teaching my
grandkids i'm just saying
[Laughter]
no no jack wagon excuses i love it
well here's the thing you guys you're
gonna look you're gonna work for a
company one day look one
in 2016 1.8 million degrees were
conferred at the college level
of that almost 400 000 were business
degrees
the next closest was all medical fields
combined at 118
000 across the us so
you're going to work for a business you
better know what you're
doing with your money wow you need
business education and the foundation is
personal finance and using financial
literacy and look i'll tell you what
kids in the 9th 10th 11th 12th grade
they can learn financial literacy
and be more verse and more conversant
than many many adults that i know yeah
than most of their parents
for sure well when they got a teacher
like you and a curriculum like ours we
can
tag team and cause that to happen chris
we're proud of you chris rusher
at uh man at williamstown
west virginia williamstown high school
absolutely
incredible been teaching our high school
curriculum for years
what a great teacher having a guy like
that at the front of the classroom
that's studly right there
very fun teacher appreciation month here
at ramsey check it out
ramseysolutions.com
teacher giveaway
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage david and becky
are with us hey guys how are you hi good
how are you
good it's real easy to read your shirts
we're debt-free
i love it congratulations i like the i
like the theme shirts very good
how much have you paid off we paid off
about 315
1996. wow gracious how long did this
take
took about 53 months 53 months and your
range of income during that time
we're kind of weird we went down we went
from 136 to about 105.
cool what do y'all do for a living i'm
retired
she's a housewife and uh i'm working
part-time right now
okay all right nice retirement income
not bad
very cool so i'm guessing with all these
numbers
that you paid off your house yes yes we
did
look at that weird people wow going into
retirement with a paid for house in
spokane washington what's the house
worth
uh it keeps going up fast yeah worth
seven did you say last it's worth about
seven
yeah or so and we actually live in athel
idaho idaho okay just over the line okay
just over the line yeah all right
very cool wow that's beautiful wonderful
so tell us your story what happened 53
months ago that put you on this journey
well a lot of it has to do with our
daughter
uh she was in the hospital we were
living in l.a at the time or orange
county in california
and we she she was just not doing well
she was in life support yeah so
um so we before that happened we were
looking to get out of california
and move so we found idaho and we had a
house that we bought out there and at
that time
she wasn't in the hospital now she was
after we bought the house
and actually she went from the hospital
bed
um he picked her up to the to idaho we
just drove her
from the hospital because they kept her
there for a few months wow
how old she was she was about 24.
wow what happened to her seven now uh
she had issues with
drugs oh my gosh yeah yeah wow is she
okay now
oh yeah i'm doing way better now yeah oh
praise god that's awesome what a great
story then
yeah so this crisis made you stop and
look at your money is that what you're
saying
well we were looking at where you live
and everything right yes we were on our
way it's weird because we were on our
way
for our anniversary to go celebrate an
anniversary he goes oh let's go to um
canada
get a hotel you know go eat out there
for dinner and i'm like
okay and then we went to the mailbox
first we stopped there and then we um
looked at a
another medical bill we're like we can't
go i told him we can't
i go he goes well let's just go drive
out there for lunch i said
okay so um we drove out there and
he it was well worth it because i end up
seeing one of my
star starry hilter this one yeah we're
watching a youtube lady that kind of got
us out to idaho yeah
and by chance we stopped at a safe way
to use the restroom and
her and her husband were there wow like
yeah so
she got her picture taken with her yeah
and i'm like well i think god worked it
out that i got to see her you know
yeah even though you know i was feeling
like oh my gosh you know we were so much
in debt
huh so what happened after that though
is
i started in my new job and we went down
to boise
and on the trip there is when we heard
our your radio station
and we were just so in debt we had all
the debt
you can imagine we had two tsp loans we
had
car payment we were driving in a nice
lexus that she loved with with the seat
warmers
um insurance payments we had all kinds
of stuff just
all the stupid stuff and halfway through
we're driving around the snake river and
and just listening and and we hear you
do the rant
the you know you can do this you can get
out of this you know we're like
yeah yeah we should get out of here we
got to get out of where we are we're
just
we are sick and tired of this so we
bought beans and rice that we first
we got there and started eating beans
and rice since then right
yep yep and we stopped at a thrift store
and bought like a 10 year old copy of
your total money makeover there you go a
good worn one
good worn one experienced book we
started highlighting it and
uh it was game on at that point
now so i have a question throughout this
journey uh what was the hardest thing
you all had to endure
eating beans and rice every day
well the hardest thing to endure was
saying no learning how to say no to our
to our kids to things that we were just
used to doing
and uh we just you know we were not no
people were kind of we were
uh we kind of enabled our kids in a lot
of ways
and we learned not to do that anymore we
were just kind of growing
he helped us grow through this um
and of course jesus christ as well yeah
and so it was just uh uh just that that
would be the hardest
part just learning to say no and and
just you know
praying uh hard and and just just
budgeting the budget was
wonderful you know that every dollar was
just awesome
and our grocery bill was how much 700
and it went down to three seven hundred
dollars for two people
for kids well we had three five total
all right
yeah that was good yeah to 300 just
beans and rice and
whatever i could get what and everybody
survived yeah
now you're going into retirement without
a house payment or anything hey man
how's that feel it feels wonderful yeah
i'm so proud of you guys
yeah i mean you really embraced the
whole idea and said i'm gonna
i'm gonna live like no one else so that
later i can live and
give like no one else which is of course
the byline on your shirt right
amen yeah amen oh and another thing that
was really hard
is he um did sell my lexus and we only
had one car
so we could um live like no one else
ouch
so now what are you gonna do now what
the house is paid for get a new car
and pay cash for it yeah he wants a
truck and you
pay cash for it and i'll eventually get
a car yeah i was thinking you owe her
alexis i do
yeah i'm thinking i'm thinking this is
coming back up if you don't handle it
brother i'm just warning you here okay
there's a process here there's an ebb
and flow in this
way to go you guys awesome well done who
are your biggest cheerleaders
or i guess i are thinking our pastor and
his wife because he did
let us lead the class oh so you've led
financial peace twice
oh well thank you yes that keeps you on
track too doesn't it to being
to be yes uh you know when you're
coordinating it's hard to not do the
stuff
that's right yeah with our first class
we were kind of doing our
doing our you know doing our own thing
too at
that that was going on paying off debt
what that was going on in the house we
were force-feeding it
and then we got that done and our second
one we were debt-free already so it was
nice
yeah that's sweet yeah well done you
guys well we've got a copy of rachel
cruz's latest new york times best seller
for you
know yourself know your money you've
done so well congratulations how fun
look at you man it's amazing so proud of
you
good stuff all right david and becky
from spokane washington 315
000 paid off in 53 months house and
everything we're looking at weird people
136 to 105 income count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one we're debt-free
this is how it's done
you know it is so interesting that
sometimes families have a
family crisis like their daughter's
illness
and it sets them back
destroys them yeah and other times they
use it as a reason
to go wait a minute this is our wake-up
call yeah we have to change
and it's the same exact situation it's
more how you respond
to the situation and that tells you
where you're going to end up five years
after it
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i love that
hearing their story they used something
that was painful and
actually turned it into something that
was the fire behind them to change
in their life and not just their life
but their future children's and great
grandchildren's lives as well yeah
and that i think for me that's that's so
exciting just to hear that
because some people would use that as an
excuse dave yeah yeah i said no we can't
do it we need to focus on that and it
was like hey we're going to focus on
this and change yeah this is the no
excuses theme hour yes sir
i like it well done good stuff good
stuff
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today
he is the host of the table on youtube
and as a podcast
you need to check it out both ways lots
of fun and
very profitable discussions happen
around that
table be sure and check it out the table
as a podcast or youtube
subscribe and uh you'll be glad you did
and of course number one best-selling
author of the book
debt free degree barbara is with us in
newark delaware hi barbara welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
well i retire in may after 21 years of
nursing
wow and i i wanted to uh know
whether i should be paying off my house
with some of my 401
or whether i should keep paying it
monthly
so when how i know you like paid off
houses how long
how old are you and a half
66 and how much is in your 401k
i have two we switch so i have two
92 in one of them and six um
698 in the other wow look at you
a millionaire nurse
[Music]
just i'm terrible spending so i'm new to
you terrible
good at working i'm uh well i'm proud of
you this is pretty incredible
it's awesome way to go how much of this
you obviously didn't inherit your 401k
money
did you have big inheritance money that
made you a millionaire
nothing no you just worked just hard
work
21 years of nursing yeah
that's impressive barbara started late
after my children went to school
yeah wow and yeah at 46 years old you go
do this right now you're 66 20 or
45 years old so uh correct don't tell me
you can't it's too late my gosh look at
barbara
and so uh uh what's it take to pay off
your house
i'm 179. i'll do it tomorrow i'll do it
tomorrow absolutely
okay now just take the two 292 and just
yeah what about the taxes that are
involved you'll have to say you have to
set some taxes out there'll be
a full tax rate on that yeah and so get
in touch with your tax professional
yeah get in touch with your tax
professional so you know how much to
pull out because you need to pull out
enough to cover the taxes
as well okay good news is the taxes
won't be due
until uh this time next year right
okay because you're doing it in this
calendar year and so
when you file the taxes is when you'll
have this this tax bill due
on this but you don't want it to
surprise you or sneak up on you or
anything and so
do you have any other monies other than
these 401ks
uh no those are my two big savings i
have 6000 in my savings account
and when i cash out everything here in
may i'll have about 18 000 put into
emergency fund
good good okay well done kiddo
so what's your house worth thanks when
um well it's about 280 to 300 in this
market
okay good for you wow yeah so i'm
talking to a lady that's worth a million
two
yep uh with a with a paid for house and
um her house represents about a third of
her net worth
you know what you are you fit the exact
template of what we found when we
studied millionaires and we stayed 10
000 of them
for the everyday millionaires project
and you were you're just exactly in
there
i mean you're incredible i am so proud
of you well done
thank you dave so thank you honor to
speak to you this is
yeah dave this is really the the theme
hour no excuse excuses
and my single mom yeah started at around
45 46 years old
we don't know what happened up to that
point right but at that point you start
with zero
yep and you have a million dollars in
your 401ks wow
and an almost paid for 300 000 house
where we reach over and pay it off yeah
and uh net worth does not change by the
way when you do that
because you're reducing the debt by the
exact same amount you reduce the savings
and so her net worth remains the same
and uh she's got plenty of money left to
live on and not a payment
in the freaking world and she's a
millionaire nurse
at 66 years old please america
remember you can do this oh my gosh
i don't know how i mean i've got to
spoon feed some of you
unbelievable what's it take to make some
of you believe
that'll do it man that's incredible wow
absolutely incredible hey kelly keep up
with her absolutely i want to i want to
talk to her later
uh-oh yeah that's good man that's
amazing absolutely that's just because
my gosh i mean wow because here's the
thing
when you're 45 yeah and i don't let's
call it a divorce i don't know what
happened maybe her husband passed away i
don't know
right but but um something happened yes
and you're by yourself
yep and you got no money and you got
kids
what are you gonna do yeah well
you know women can't get ahead
well you know single moms they don't
have a chance
hey and then you could believe that you
can sit in the corner suck your thumb
and hope that the government will take
care of you at retirement or you can go
be a student
yes wow what a stud at that's amazing
66 years old 21 years later
she's a millionaire as a nurse
she's not a lawyer she didn't play in
the nba
and she doesn't have a rock band she
just did the practical
things that we teach get out of debt
and vest and live below your means
because her house is not even that
expensive dave like you could tell she
literally did
our stuff when she learned about it and
it works
yeah bottom line and now i got people
listening to me right now that are broke
living in a million-two house
right yeah driving two freaking cars in
the driveway they're 50 000 a piece and
you fleeced them
and then you're scratching your head and
crying because america hasn't got any
opportunity no you're just stupid yeah
that's the only problem anything to do
with opportunities got through
stupid that's it you're just walking
around wearing stupid around your neck
every day and then wondering why you're
broke
no excuses you know this is cray cray
man
i love that woman she's so inspiring
because she represents the fact that you
if you're listening to me right now
you can do this yeah now dave now since
she's at the retirement age she has a
million dollars let's say well she has
about 800
000 cash liquid in her 401k does she
pull from a 401k or does she just
live off the interest oh definitely
living off the interest yeah i mean
what's the ballpark of benches you think
i mean if she's got 800 000 and it made
10 percent that'd be 80 grand
right that's a b which is probably more
than she was making
exactly all about to say with no bills
80 grand a year that's a beautiful
salary for someone else
living in a 300 house 66 years old shut
up
wow this just drive i mean this jams me
up right here wow
i'm telling you guys i i um i
i i understand pain
yeah from having done stupid things i
have been in a pile
of stupid myself that i made for myself
so i know exactly what it looks like i
know exactly how it feels
but what i will not accept from any of
you
is that you can't do it so good
henry ford said if you think you can or
you think you can't you're right
yep and uh is it hard well of course
it's hard
yeah if it wasn't hard every little
duper would do it
every little wuss would do it no you got
to be a stud you got to be a student to
do it right
got to but day listen about it i want it
it's hard
and i want it to be hard because later
on it's going to be
easier so now her retirement is easier
because she was willing to put into work
and work like no one else does if it's
easy up front it's gonna be hard in the
ending if
it's hard up front you are gonna pay a
price which end do you wanna pay it on
there you go dave
and how big a price you wanna pay by the
way if you pay the price up front it's a
smaller price
absolutely here's the idea you retire at
65 you live
25 years on social insecurity
11 to 1 300 a month eating alpo
or you can freaking do this stuff one of
the two
which price do you want to pay i'm you
know
you may not go on vacation you don't
want me dave ramsey doesn't want me to
have any fun oh shut
up i want you to have the biggest fun
ever yes and you can have the biggest
fun ever when you have some
money and you're not broken whiny let's
go dave oh my gosh
this is awesome what a neat lady she
fired me up can you tell
yes i think the whole hour fired us up
sure that teacher man yes he jacked it
up too
pay cash for a home no excuse is a
teacher who paid cash for him
yeah love this good hour anthony o'neil
ramsey personality james childs is the
producer kelly daniel is our associate
producer and phone screener
i'm dave ramsey i cause trouble
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host anthony o'neil ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today
as we talk to you about your life and
your money
it is a free call some say the advice is
worth exactly what you pay for it the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five travis is in
jacksonville florida start this hour off
what's up with you travis
uh hey dave and anthony pleasure to
speak with you guys you too
how can we help um i've been listening
to you for
about a month now and i feel like i have
a decision to make
um apparently the only debt i have is on
my truck i have about
20 000 on it and i've got
20 000 sitting in a cd that i moved
out of my roth a couple years ago
kind of a dumb decision i realized that
now
but i wasn't making anything at the time
with
the credit union that i'm at and so
i have another 20 000 in my savings so i
have my three to six months
um emergency fund saved up in your
trucks your only question is
yeah so i guess my question is should
it's only
been in the city for two years should i
go ahead and pull it out of there
and just pay the truck off it's not in a
it's not in a roth ira today it's just
in a cd and you've already paid whatever
penalty or taxes you had to pay right
um it was moved from a roth ira
to a roth cd oh it is a roth
still yes
well it's still a roth ira then it's
just a cd in the roth ira is that what
you're saying
um yeah i guess so okay well it's it
matters
to give you the ant the correct answer
okay if you simply cashed it out
and put it into a cd and it's no longer
in a roth ira
then i would use the money and pay off
the truck but
if it is in a roth ira i'm not moving it
out
i'm going to move it out of that credit
union with a smartvestor pro into some
mutual funds in a roth
and do a rollover so you need to figure
out
you need to figure out what it really is
okay
how old are you i'm 28
okay and you're single i take it i'm
engaged good for you when are you
getting married
um we don't have a date yet but um
probably within the next year
good for you and what do you make
i'm on track to make 84 this year okay
i love it so what are you seeing i'm
saying the same thing as su dave too
um i'm curious of travis what do you i
want to focus on what are you going to
do in moving forward
you know with your money um because
you're going to do that there
but what are you doing forward with your
money as far as in uh to set you up to
win
long term well i've actually got an
appointment this saturday
to uh sit down with one of your smart
investor crews nice um
to get it into some mutual funds so
that's what i'm doing right now um i
still contribute to my roth ira and have
a 401k with a six percent match
so i'll put 10 in there and practice in
the roth ira
okay okay well i'm going to put you on
the if you're going to follow our stuff
and you said you just been watching us
for a few weeks if you're starting to
believe
that what we teach you will cause you to
be wealthy the quickest
and easiest although there is no quick
and easy but this is the shortest
distance
between two points if you're starting to
believe that the way you would apply the
baby steps to your situation would be
one of two ways way way number one
this cd is not a roth when you get into
it and you just discover i cashed out my
for
my roth a while back and it's just
sitting there in a cd
if that's the case i use that money
today and pay off the truck or
after saturday you can take that
paperwork into your smart vista pro they
can tell you what you've got
uh you pay off the truck with that money
uh
if it is a roth then you're gonna roll
it
to mutual funds in a roth with the smart
vista pro
and you're going to take the money the
other pile of money and pay off the
truck yeah
and then you're going to rebuild your
emergency fund with no payments and with
your income
okay that one's uncomfortable but that's
following the baby steps exactly you'd
leave a thousand dollars in the bank
and you pay off your truck as soon as
possible or you sell the truck one of
the two but i think you keep the truck
in your situation yeah it's not an
unreasonable truck
you can do this and you can rebuild your
emergency fund in two months three
months
because you don't have a truck payment
anymore right now you've got a 600 truck
payment
yeah and and make sure yeah yeah
and travis this is the only debt you
have correct no credit cards
nothing else no student loans nope
okay good for you all right that's it so
way number one is
if it is a roth you use your other
savings account pay off the truck and
you roll the roth
to mutual fund roth okay with your
smartvestor pro if it's not a roth
then use that money and pay off your
truck and that finishes you baby step
three and you start putting 15
of your income away baby step four into
your 401k
and your roths and you can open a roth
with the smart buster pro
that day as well if you're doing that
but if you're
if it is if it is a roth you are out of
money
because you've used up all your money
and you don't need to start any
retirement plans until you get the
emergency fund rebuilt yes because we
got to walk back through that but it
won't take you but a few months so by
the time you get married you're going to
be debt free
and have your retirement well underway
and have an emergency fund in place
you're going to be in really really good
shape
it's beautiful yeah it's good stuff man
he ate man
very smart jonathan's with us jonathan's
in orlando hi jonathan how are you
hey i'm doing good thank you for taking
my call sure how can we help
my question is i'm debating if i should
change the
job that i have just because the income
is not steady and it's not consistent
and there's not much of it is a sales
occupation and there's not much of it
i'm so correct not enough that i see
myself
uh being in my older years or maybe
inconsistently making a hundred thousand
dollars a month is okay
so it's not the inconsistencies the
problem you're not making any money
yeah correct and what are you selling
um electronics electronics for who yeah
like are you
like one of those tv companies oh
yeah something similar to that correct
yeah yeah or cable companies
yeah and what do you what are you
thinking about transitioning to
um that's the thing i'm not too sure
i know within my employer i tried moving
up the corporate ladder
and yeah even though there is a small
increase in pay
what i've noticed is in sales management
sometimes you rely on others to make
your income and i think that's where
as a go-getter kind of feel
uncomfortable
uh yeah what'd you make last year what'd
you pay taxes on last year
so since you're consistent last year i
only made
30 000 but the year before uh kovit i
was able to make 55 60.
okay well i mean if you can make 55 or
60 it's a different thing but if you
want to move out of this
get in touch with ken coleman at
kencoleman.com he can give you the
guidance on your career
change uh it sounds like you're changing
careers that's what it sounds like to me
yeah i think you've already decided that
you just wanted us to say it out loud
with you
inconsistent income's never the problem
it's the fact there's not enough income
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
debt-free degree is my co-host today
today's question comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping
and new promos all the time always use
the magic word the promo code
ramsey today's question dave comes from
sarah wisconsin she says my daughter is
a high school
honor student student and is very
ambitious she has twenty thousand
dollars in mutual funds and twenty three
thousand dollars in savings
wow uh should we open an ira for her
with the twenty three thousand dollars
we already have sixteen thousand dollars
set aside for college uh dave
um in wisconsin uh the average um
cost of college out there i saw was
about in between ten and thirteen
thousand dollars a year
tuition alone tuition alone so that
means she's gonna need about 40
000 to go off to college and that's not
counting room and board
exactly so my advice would be neither
save all of that money for college
agreed
so this way you know she can get through
college without racking up debt and then
once she
graduates college i mean with no debt
gets a job
then yes let's go ahead and fully fund
the emergency fund and start investing
it
yeah so let's let's pan back just a
second we have an honor student
yes yes that somehow
has twenty thousand dollars in mutual
funds wow somehow
has twenty three thousand dollars in
savings yes what we have here
is a kid that has amazing potential
absolutely
this kid's not a loser yeah this kid's
going places and this kid may get some
scholarships and this kid
is the best possible investment of that
money yes this kid
if you invest it into the kid into their
education into a
usable degree field yeah a degree field
where you
get a job not left-handed puppetry yeah
not some kind of stupid but you know
crazy nuanced degree but something where
there's actually use in the marketplace
for the knowledge
with this amazing young woman yeah
then the money that she will make extra
because of that education and because of
that education being debt-free
is much greater than the money she would
make on that roth ira mutual fund
you said it well dave so what's a better
investment
the kid yes because this is a kid worth
investing
yes into herself yeah you investing into
her
and to because her future is freaking
bright absolutely
and so just give her some guidance on
going to a college you pay cash for
give her some or that she gets
scholarships and gets to go free too
i don't care where it is where's the
cheapest place to go to school
within reason that you can pay for now
this kid may be able to go to an
expensive school and they give it to her
absolutely that's possible very possible
and still you're going to need
another 30 000 to get through four years
of just miscellaneous crap yeah
books uh you know travel or you know
whatever
housing i don't know what it is you're
going to be into something so you're
going to need this money
even if she gets a free ride to muckety
muck school yes
or she just goes to state school and
pays state tuition either one yeah
now you know we can add to that if you
want to lower the cost
of education let's start taking college
equivalents
in those ap classes and knock out i mean
we talked to one the other day i don't
remember it was you and me or ken
and me but uh that the uh kid was out of
school in two and a half years because
they took college equivalence in high
school i mean that that's golden i would
hope that this smart young
honor student yeah she's she's doing
that because
she could actually go in there go into
school and talk about this in debt free
degree
she can go into her college experience
as a rising sophomore yeah
yeah and then that saves you you know
right there one-fourth of it exactly of
whatever it is
whatever it is and you already have
sixty thousand dollars for the twenty
twenty three and the sixteen counts
what's the worst case scenario
money-wise mathematics-wise to this
woman's point the worst case scenario is
you don't need hardly any of this money
and she gets out of school
yeah four years from now three years
from now with
forty thousand dollars in the bank and
it's made no money for four years or
three years
that's that's and now you invest it
that's what you lose but that's what
you're laughing well julie's you lost
the potential income
on a mutual fund for three or four years
while you did the right thing and that's
invest in this studly kid
yeah this kid's amazing absolutely so
this is the kind of stuff anthony talks
about all the time on the table and he
also talks about it in debt-free degree
yeah you can go to college debt-free
just because the stupid government which
can't balance its own books suggest
student loans
and won't stop this epic disaster called
the student loan program
that is screwing up people's lives all
over america
just because it's normal out there to
get a student loan in a world that's
broke where normal sucks
doesn't mean your kid has to get a
student loan
maybe your kid has some sense because
mom and daddy grew a brain
right right and had a little backbone
yeah and tells the kid how things are
going to be
because after all it's a kid they're not
grown ups yet
and they're not mature enough to uh to
make that decision on their own yeah a
guy calls me up and he's like
from michigan and says i've saved 80 000
but my what am i gonna do my kid told me
they're gonna go to a more expensive
school and i said well see that you
ruined that whole thing back at six
years old because
at six years old when my kid figured out
they don't tell me stuff i tell them
stuff
exactly so that then we get control of
who's
who are they freaking inmates running
the asylum or not yeah
that's what we're doing there oh
changing subjects a few weeks ago the
irs announced that it's publishing the
federal tax pushing the federal tax
deadline back
everyone in the us is now automatically
gets an extra month to file
with the date moved from april 15th to
may 17th and that's for federal returns
folks
not estimated quarterly payments and not
necessarily in your state
if you have stated cub tax due it'll
depend on your state why did it get
pushed back while the pandemic is still
affecting things and when you throw in
the very recent tax changes
april 15th deadline was looking like a
lot of trouble for a lot of people
with the change to may 17th you've got
an extra month to not just
file but also to pay your tax bill
if you're in texas oklahoma or louisiana
your tax date
from the irs is still june 15th because
of the storms that hit you
so what does all this mean well it means
you have extra time most of you do
to file most of your taxes but if you
can file now
especially if you're due for a refund
you should do it immediately and that
advice comes from the irs which
doesn't matter we don't take advice from
the irs if you need help filing
either online or with a trusted tax
advisor
ramsay can hook you up text tax
three three seven eight nine get it done
text
tax two three three seven
eight nine andrew is in boston
hey andrew welcome to the ramsey show
hey thanks for having me on sure what's
up
so um i'm 24 years old i'm engaged and
i'm about to marry somebody with
220 000 in student debt
should doctor or lawyer
uh no she's she's gonna be a doctor of
veterinary medicine
okay good okay all right yeah so i'm
saving up enough money and plan to have
enough cash by the time she's done with
school to be able to pay off that debt
in cash
wow what are you doing yeah
i'm a chemical engineer okay what are
you making
i make about 135 a year wow and when do
you all get married
we are getting married in two months and
when does she graduate
she graduates three years from now so
just to give you a breakdown on the debt
she has 60 from undergrad
she's one year in so she has 40 from
that
and then each three years is
accumulating another 40. so
are you going to cash flow hers from
this point forward
that's that's my question i'm not sure
because
yeah i would do that i would do that
before i paid on the existing debt yeah
you got a good income and a good plan
and a good head on your shoulders one
thing about chemical engineering they
taught you math right
yeah now is she working while she's in
college as well no
she's not probably not is she no i mean
it's hard for veterinarians yeah yeah
eight to five it's like going to med
school yeah it's hardcore
yeah yeah man i i don't think you should
be saving
to pay off debt i think you should be
cash flowing cash flow is job one
any money above being able to cash flow
her way out that you can throw back at
the debt
is job too yes so what about
investing then would you not none let's
get her out of school and get this
cleared up before we do anything
yeah she's a good investment like we
were just talking about yep
this is a good investment she's going to
make a great income assuming she chooses
well on how to
use her dvm there are dvms that make
more than
medical doctors lots of them because
they
chose how they were going to operate
their practice in a
in a way that was uh successful with
money now some dvms get caught up in
you know uh going 200 000 in debt and
then don't make any money because
they're not careful on how they build
their career
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk to you about
your life and your money it's a free
call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
joe is in austin texas hi joe welcome to
the ramsay show
hello sir long time listener you i love
you miss
i love your ministry and i love what you
and your disciples do
thank you i really do i would not be
where i'm at today
if it was not you well i'm proud of you
i know and
and i mean that i uh just a quick
question i'll get right to it sir
um i i've been in the tsp funds
now for over 20 years
and um i'm in uh the cnsi the csi funds
as you recommend yes sir but i'm
wondering when i get
ready to retire sir do i just keep it
like that or do i shift the funds
i i would roll it out to an ira in good
mutual funds because you can find mutual
funds that will outperform that mix in
the tsp
okay also get get with the smart
investor pro and do an ira rollover
into an ira and pick out some mutual
funds that you want it spread into how
much have you got in the tsp
i'll have about six hundred thousand
where you go joe
yeah baby wow
wow i love it how old are you
right now right now on 58
58 years old he has 600 000 bucks so
and uh is your house paid off
uh no no it's not sir
yes well i'm i'm selling my house sir
and
i'm uh and i'm i'm buying a new one and
i got it
i bought this purchase i'm purchasing
this house at the perfect time i
purchased it at the low end
and i'm gonna be selling my house at the
higher end so
i'm going to be throwing 50 down that
the property's going to cost me about
400 000
and i'm throwing 200 000 down on here on
a 15-year
mortgage yeah so you're almost a
millionaire already
because of you i didn't give you any
money you did it
well the advice you gave me and i never
make any big decisions
without check i listen to you every
morning uh
i i don't make any big decisions without
trying to reach the show or research it
first
wow well i'm honored i'm so proud of you
joe
very very well done yeah so i you know
you retire from the federal government
uh and you have the thrift savings plan
the tsp
you had it invested properly in that
but the c plan is the uh common stock
index plan and it's pretty much like an
s p 500 index
and the i is the international and the s
is the small company uh you can sit down
with the smart investor pro
and find a better mix of mutual funds
that will outperform those three indexes
uh not by a ton but by enough that it's
worth doing
and also that way you've got it under
your thumb to manage it all these years
in retirement because you're only 58. i
mean you're going to be managing this
for 30 years
at least right i mean to 88 right so um
you know you've got a lot of years to
make this money perform make it do what
it's
supposed to do so uh very good job
and by the way anthony that's just a
reminder anytime you leave whether it's
retirement or otherwise
you always take your 401k with you your
retirement plan with you in the form of
an ira rollover and the reason is
number one you've got better control
yeah and you're watching it more closely
number two you've got a lot more options
there's eight thousand mutual funds to
choose from to put your ira into
and most for like 401k say dave i think
it's right around like four or five
options
right maximum maybe 12 or something like
that i think we got 10 or 12 here yeah
but and we've got really good options
here and you're not gonna
i mean if i were to retire which i'm not
ever going to i'm just going to die but
um
but the uh if i were to retire i would
roll it to an ira
and but i don't think i would get
substantially better options than the
401k options
i picked for my 401k plan here at ramsey
i mean i picked them out right
so me and the smartvestor pro you know
right and we designed this plan
because i'm no good mutual fund so but
but so i'm not going to outperform this
401k
substantially but most of the time you
could yeah yeah yeah that's simple
i love it phoenix is our julio is with
us in phoenix i'm sorry hi julio how are
you
how you doing mr ramsey better than i
deserve what's up in your world
uh so i have a couple questions for you
um i'm selling my current
house and want to take the equity from
this house to
put down the down payment on the other
house that i'm going to buy
my question is how much of the equity
should i put down
all of it unless you have debt do you
have debt
uh by the time i i
finished the selling version of the
house i should be out of bed
good yeah so do you need the money for
anything other than buying a house
uh i don't have any uh
any money on retirement so i was
wondering if
it's wise to save some size for
retirement and put the rest on
that no i would just start i would just
start putting money into your retirement
15
of your income going into retirement
after you're out of debt and have your
emergency fund in place
here's the thing having money going into
a 401k and having a paid for house are
the two elements we most often find in
our data points of people who become
millionaires
and so your highest probability chance
of becoming a millionaire
is paying off your house and building
money in your 401k and your roth iras
right so if one of the goals is paying
off the house then putting as much down
on the house as possible
it gets you closer to having a paid for
house yeah
okay now let me ask you julio too one of
the key things we talk about is have an
emergency fund
outside of your equity do you have
anything sitting in a side of a savings
account for emergencies
no not right now that's what i was
thinking maybe i should take some of the
equity
you probably should do that yeah yeah
you should do that because i don't want
you moving into a house broke
yeah there you go right yeah and
but no i would not use it for retirement
and no i would not use it to buy a car
and no i would not use it to go on
vacation i would use it to get out of
debt on your house as fast as possible
so be on your other than the emergency
fund i would throw it all at the house
that's a good catch anthony yeah
good job there open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five alissa is in
cincinnati
hey alyssa welcome to the ramsay show
thanks for having me sure how can we
help um my
husband and i he's sitting right here
with me so we
are on baby step two we have around i'm
we're 25. i have i say we
because we're married now we got married
two months ago so congratulations
thank you so we have about 30 000 in the
bank the only
debt that we have is my student loans
i'm a nurse he's a firefighter
so we have 32 000 from my student loans
and then his paramedic school he just
started
about a month ago by the end of it it's
only a year
he will it's about eight thousand
dollars so there's that
so he used to drive a ford f-150 we sold
that
thanks to your plan we sold that and
paid so that we had about 24
800 left on that loan and then we sold
it for 27.5
so we made money off of that which was
nice um and then paid for a camry and
cash so we have
no car payments i was driving a 2011
chevy cruze
and then it crapped out on me so i had
that one
for six years and the engine shot so i
guess our question is
um we with the 30 000 that we have in
the bank and keeping
the debt in mind obviously like which
direction should we go and how much we
should pay for a car for me because i'm
currently carless right now
well for the first thing i'm going to
say you're going to take 8 000 of that
and you're going to put that towards the
school so that way we're not racking up
any more debt
then i'm taking the rest of that and i'm
going to sit there and talk about okay
i'm going to buy cash cards cheap as
possible
and then i'll put the rest of that
towards my debt if you need a car
now the key thing is if you need the car
if you don't need the car if you all can
work
you know another six months with sharing
cars great i'm putting all towards the
debt but
eight thousand dollars of cash flow
schools so we're not racking up any more
debt
and then i'm gonna buy a cheap very
cheap affordable
reliable car and then i'm putting the
rest of it towards my debt two thousand
dollars
and then you put eight thousand with the
for the school that leaves you
20 to throw with a 32 student loan you
got 12 000 in student loans to pay off
is your next big goal and you start
working you keep working
your debt snowball at that point and
then when you get out of this mess
you're going to move up in cars because
you're both driving crappy cars
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
i'm dave ramsey
this is the ramsey show chad is with us
in minneapolis hi
chad how are you very good how are you
better than i deserve praying for your
city brother
[Music]
how can we help today looking
at what do you suggest for life
insurance for blended families
um i have four children she has two
um i'm the breadwinner uh between the
two of us
and right now i currently have some
policies you know set up for
my children she really has nothing
we just bought we just bought a house um
that would
house all six um we have both of us have
50 50 custody
of all of our children if something were
to happen to all any one either one of
us
we would essentially lose custody of
those of the others children
how do you recommend sort of
dividing out and planning for
life insurance when when i want to help
support
my wife but i also want to support my
current wife but i also want to support
my
my children and how do i
come up with that formula uh
10 times to 12 times
what each one of them would need
per year in the event of your death
okay so let's run some numbers let's
just play with some play a game here
okay
so let's just start with your current
wife has
three children from her former marriage
that would still be with her were you
to pass away let's start with you okay
what would she need from you
to make sure your wife is taken care of
upon your death per year in income
do you have any assets do you have a
bunch of debt what kind of situation are
we in financially
me neither will neither one of us have
any debt um we have
we have equity in our homes um you know
i
i make i make 120 she makes 40.
um the the house that we have is
way way bigger than like if something
happened to me
it's it's there's no reason that she
would need a six-bedroom house for
her and her two and and her two
daughters yeah um so she would like some
kind of right you don't have to do it
right now but here the answer to the
question is run the scenario out
and let's just let's just throw out a
number okay let's say
that you wanted to make sure in addition
to her 40
that she had another 60 000 a year
coming in
okay so 10 to 12 times that for her
on you okay
and so uh you know that sounds a lot
like 750 000
bucks i'm making these numbers up it
might not be that but i'm
teaching you how to do the formula okay
then on your kids they're going to your
ex-wife
but you want to make sure that they're
okay and you would cover the equivalent
of child support
plus some probably plus college and cars
right and so uh three kids through
college
three kids you said there's three right
i've got four four okay how old are they
uh 13 to four okay and you want to
support
them not your ex but them
right to make sure they have that she
has the money to raise them
and that they've got the money to go to
college is probably another half million
dollars
okay and that would give them like three
or four thousand dollars a month plus
have a pile of money there
when they get ready to go to school and
that money
is the the beneficiary on that money is
a
family trust that you put directions
in the trust it's formed upon your death
the life insurance beneficiary is the
children's trust
and the trustee will conduct the money
the way you
want them to conduct it and so in my old
trust when our kids were minors it said
it would be invested in the four types
of mutual funds i teach growth growth
and income aggressive growth and
international
and then the trustee is to disperse
three thousand dollars a month to or
whatever number of dollars a month
to the mother for care and feeding of
kids
uh and if there's any major medical the
trustee can disperse for that
they can disperse for their first car up
to x
and they can disperse for college and
whatever is left after college is handed
to the kiddo
right ex-wife has no money access
trustee of the trust is not kin to
ex-wife
correct and that's like your brother
or whatever that kind of a thing or
something like that
may well probably wouldn't be your
current wife because she probably
doesn't want to deal with all this
later but um that's probably that'd
probably get real messy and toxic but um
but anyway someone you trust that's why
we call them a trustee
and you put all this in your will and so
i'm gonna guess
and say you know you're making a hundred
thousand and some change you're probably
gonna need a little over a million
dollars but that's about what it would
have been
in a traditional setting we're just
divvying it up as a matter of fact you
could do
one policy for one million two and
current wife gets seven
kids trust gets 500 in the beneficiary
you can have one policy and split
beneficiary and it's cheaper it's
cheaper to buy one policy
but and again i'm making those numbers
up i'm not suggesting a million two but
it's probably going to land
something about like what we just talked
out unless you want to raise it or lower
what you're giving them monthly and uh
and what you're taking care of if your
ex-wife is a multi-millionaire
you may not be that concerned with this
right
yes she makes more money than that more
money than i do so
i'm not i'm i'm not too worried about
the kids
day-to-day life yeah it's
just making sure that there's something
you know in the event that something
happened to me
like my my inheritance coming to me
would would would
would get divvied out to my children
through that trust
um so that they'd get it when when
they're sacrificed so exactly you can
use the trust for the assets as well as
the
beneficiary position in the life
insurance
so you're and you're controlling all of
it and the ex isn't going to control it
but
and you know i don't know what kind of
basic what kind of
speaking terms you are uh with your ex
but
i would go ahead and tell her exactly
what this is going to look like
i didn't ask her i'm going to tell her
right
right yeah this is what's going on i
read the will while i'm still alive
yeah and that that way everybody can go
ahead and be pissed off if they want to
be pissed off now
right we'll get this out of the way and
there's no well david dave really meant
no dave's going to tell you what he
meant we're going to go and do that now
and that that just gets rid of the movie
scene from the bad movie with the
you know this crazy step children or
whatever all this stuff in these movie
scenes on the wheel
and so you get a will and you get life
insurance and that's a great guy
preparing for his wife and his children
absolutely dave let me ask you another
question
i'm seeing that a lot of families now
well not a lot
i've had quite a few people ask me hey
how much life insurance should i take
out on my
100 healthy child
none that's what i was thinking i just
want to make sure i'm saying the right
thing america no thank you
well i mean the only exception would be
if you're completely broken you have no
emergency fund you can get a child
writer
on your current policy that's about 10
or 15 000
for like 50 bucks a year okay it's an
attachment to your existing policy
yeah and what that would cover would be
burying your kid if something happened
to them god forbid
right right uh because you don't have
the money for a burial yeah but if
you've got 25 000
in your emergency fund and you're
debt-free uh you would god help you
yeah pay that out of your own pocket
right um and through your tears
obviously what a horrible thing to
experience but but um
children are not creating an income that
has to be replaced
now if your child is doing diaper
commercials and making a hundred
thousand dollars a year we might talk
about it
but otherwise they ain't working right
and so they don't we don't need to
replace
their income uh and 99
of child life insurance is crap whole
life
investment investing for college stuff
and it's trash
i agree just wanted to make sure i asked
a question america yeah so
yeah here's the thing anytime something
sounds kind of weird to you
it's weird it means it's a rip-off so
let me give you an example of that
gerber makes baby food
don't buy life insurance from gerber
that just sounds stupid when you say it
out loud and they sell whole life life
insurance
wait what they do you can buy a gerber
life insurance policy on your little
baby
and get screwed i mean they just will
rip you off it's unbelievable
so if you're if your life insurance came
from a baby food company
you might have got screwed really i mean
how hard is this to figure out
wow there you go wow just a thought from
old dave today
here we go that puts the sour of the
ramsey show in the books
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host anthony o'neil ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author and host of the table
a very popular podcast and youtube show
you can join him there anytime and you
can join him today here on the air with
me
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five
zack is with us in new york city to
start off this hour hey zach how are you
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i'm currently a college student and i
have a real passion for cars and i've
been doing a lot of research into a
business
that involves cars it's an app called
turo
i don't know if you're familiar it's
like this peer-to-peer car rental
service
like airbnb for cars and so i've been
i've been thinking a lot about uh
getting a car
that i can put up on this app and manage
it you know best case i'll be making
money on it or you know even if it
doesn't do so well
um at least i'll come out of college
with a car paid off or a very worst case
if it's just a total flop
i can i can sell it for a little bit of
a loss but if it lets me do something
with cars
i make money off of it i'm trying to see
what you think about that if that's
you know something risky that's worth
taking um and just to see your thoughts
on that
so you're currently in college right now
is that
yes how are you paying for college
so my parents are paying most of it i do
have
a little bit of student loans okay and
will you be taking on more student loans
to complete um
it's five thousand dollars in loans per
year yeah
no uh then right now uh you're not
buying a car man i want you to cash flow
the rest of your college experience
um i'm like you i love cars too man and
it sounds great the idea sounds great
but it sounds great once you have the
cash to actually cash flow that
experience
i don't want you putting money into a
car and you're steady borrowing money
over here to complete your education
um so i'm going to say no
sounds horrible to you but when i'm i'm
also going to tell you i promise you
down the road
if you listen to dave and i by saying
invest into yourself
cashflow the rest of your college
experience get your savings up
then once you build a solid foundation
then if you want to explore that in the
next two years after you graduate
college by all means go try it out but
the key thing in
there is pay cash for the car you know
that's going to be the bottom line
so when i was your age when i was your
age i was as
entrepreneurial as you are you've got a
a real passion for looking around making
money you not only like cars you like
to work a deal yeah and you like to make
the the whole
process of the system intrigues you i
can hear it and it intrigues me i'm with
you i i completely understand that and
uh one of the things i looked at doing
when i was in school and i didn't end up
i wasn't able to do it because i guess
god protected me
was i was going to finance a whole bunch
of
these machines at the market that put
air in your car
tire and you put a quarter or whatever
in there and it turns on the air
compressor and puts air in your tire and
i was gonna borrow like ten thousand
dollars
and put these machines everywhere and of
course that was gonna make me rich
um it it would have not done that at all
it would have
caused me to take my eye off the ball i
would not have graduated from school
because i would have been screwing
around with freaking air
yeah literally and so
looking back on it when i look back on
it it really looks silly
but when i when i had the
entrepreneurial froth
when i was when i had the fever and my i
was running a fever
uh and i thought this was gonna be my my
way to wealth
i i was all about air machines you know
and i look back on it's almost humorous
now but
uh but but uh you know and that you know
honestly what you're talking about
doesn't sound that dumb
as dumb as my idea was uh but when you
look back on it it may feel dumb
yeah and as opposed to as opposed to
what anthony's saying
use your money on zach yeah zach is a
better deal
than a trendy app to airbnb your car
that you don't even own yet absolutely
and put money in zach
yeah uh and you'll have plenty of
chances to make mistakes with your
entrepreneurial zeal later
[Laughter]
i've made a living making mistakes i've
made
more mistakes than i have done smart
things many many more
but i've tried to do them in such a way
that they did not cause me to take my
eye off the ball
and they did not cause they were not
fatal errors
when i failed at them yeah and so
there's too many things wrong with this
story
you're going to go into debt you're
going to go further into that for school
which you shouldn't be doing you ought
to be working your way around that
you're going to take your eye off the
ball you're going to be worried about
this instead of your studies
you're going to be screwing around with
this stupid app and
you know it's just there's just it's
just it's
you know entrepreneurs zach we all are a
little bit add
yeah squirrel you know i mean there's
always something getting our attention
and that's what's happening to you here
and it's easy for us to sit over here on
the outside looking in and see that but
you're in the middle of it you got the
fever
so please don't do it that's the answer
to your question
and and it's a headache possibly waiting
to dave and i really want zach to hear
me one of my friends does that
and he says anthony man i just one of my
cars got into a car accident and the
last thing i want you to be worried
about is school
now this business and then now an
accident yeah and it's in your name
yes you know and i'm not sure what
insurance is
insurance has to go up because it's
peer-to-peer so it's like yeah well
or it doesn't cover it at all you know i
mean there's some
uh companies that won't cover delivering
pizza
yeah you know they won't because that's
commercial activity as far as they're
concerned you wreck your car while
you're delivering pizza they won't cover
you
and so you need to you need to look at
all that and and that's or don't look at
all of it because you're not doing it
right that's a better idea
open phones a triple eight eight two
five
two you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money
uh juan asks on facebook where do
student loans
fit into your seven baby steps student
loans
as far as i'm paying them all fits in at
baby step number two
all right it doesn't matter where they
are baby step number two paying off all
your debt using the debt
snow ball just line them up if you have
a credit card that's 500 and if you have
a car that's 10 000
your student loans are 20 000 it's gonna
be third in line
you know and so it falls into baby step
number two
there's a an emotional temptation when
the student loans especially when
they're large
to try to treat them in a later baby
step like they're a mortgage
yeah but that is a mistake huge mistake
you need to get rid
of them yeah if it's a mountain you need
to
tear that mountain down and a lot of
people right now dave are waiting
for the government to see what you know
our new president and congress is going
to do
since you don't have to make any
payments since you don't have any
interest securing on it right now i'm
just going to let it sit there
and just wait for the government and i
and i will personally say this is my
personal uh opinion that is a huge
mistake if you have the money if you
have the resources
attack all of your debt right now
especially if your student loans are
your only debt
take advantage of this time of making
payments without any interest
rocking up on you and if the government
does do something down the road
great if they don't you're still moving
forward
yeah hey listen when you say the words
out loud i'm waiting on the government
to fix my life
by definition you have signed away your
life
pretty much you pretty much have signed
up for loserville
yeah the government is going to fix your
life
come on let's all laugh right now are we
ready one two three
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today our famous 10 sale is back
you can get the tools and resources you
need to make
real progress with your money and your
life offer just
10 bucks each that means
saving up to 60 on over 40 best-selling
books like the total money makeover
anthony's book debt-free degree both
number one best sellers the proximity
principle number one bestseller by ken
coleman
of course rachel's books christy's books
all the books in here
ten dollars each at the ramsey solutions
store go to
com ramseysolutions.com store and
there's more
we got a gift for you you can also enter
to win our ramsey cash giveaway
we're giving away five hundred dollars
cash every week
no purchase necessary and a grand prize
of five
thousand dollars cash be sure to go to
ramseysolutions.com to be sure you sign
up every day for that enter daily for
chances to win
no purchase is necessary you got to be
18 or older to win
text cash to 33 789
33 789
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five max is in boise idaho hi max how
are you
hey dave i'm doing good hi anthony hey
we're excited to talk to you guys today
you too what's up well i'm just hoping i
could get some
advice or counsel from both of you guys
regarding
uh a situation and a vacation home that
we have
um whether or not we should keep it
uh maybe downsize the prime home
in order to own nothing on either home
or just sell the vacation home until
a later time when we have enough money
to buy another one
how much is owed on each
so the vacation home we own nothing on
the primary resi
and it's about 500 000. the
primary residence we owe just under 150
on it's worth about 650
probably and the reason we owe the 150
on the primary is because
we took out an equity loan to finish
building the vacation home i didn't have
enough to pay for the whole thing
i have refinanced that into a 12-year
mort
but that's where that loan came from
what's your household is the only debt
we have
um i make or we make approximately a
hundred
thousand um i do normally make more than
that but that is
based on overtime so i can
count on for sure a hundred thousand um
last year i made
140 but that's not guaranteed
what other assets do you have
um besides the two homes i mean nothing
big you know we have our vehicles we
have a boat
uh but that well and we have pretty we
have pretty good retirement assets
uh but those are all in like 401k
457 roth how much digital roth accounts
uh we have between all of those about
800 000
um but in just our cash like our
emergency fund
we have fifteen to twenty thousand how
old are you
cash uh i am 48
my wife is 47.
okay my first choice is just pay off the
150
000 in like the next three years
and keep everything because i think i
hear you like this vacation home a lot
and that's where the boat is i'm pretty
sure too right
well it goes there uh it gets it's it's
the winter is pretty long there and so i
don't leave it over the winter but
gotcha um yeah i
feel like my hesitancy is just the
the um small amount of liquid cash that
we have
so in the event that my life breaks down
or something like that i run a very
detailed budget and i just don't feel
like there's money
in that budget to you know pay for a new
car
if i had to or things like that and i
if we didn't have a vacation home we
could go to that town whenever we
wanted and just do an airbnb or
something but then it would free up so
much cash that
well let me just tell you a lot i own a
couple of uh vacation homes
and they do not make sense
yeah you can always go and rent
a hundred times yeah before you could
buy
uh 200 times in a lot of cases
before you could buy i mean i rented a
house for our whole family
in the mountains in the rockies it was
thirteen thousand dollars for the week
but it's a six million dollar house and
uh how many times can i do that for
thirteen thousand versus six million i
didn't buy that house by the way but um
i rented it but uh uh you know
you just do that math you can rent that
house for the rest of your life and
and two more lifetimes before you can
afford to pay for it they don't make
sense
vacation homes are toys yes and if the
toy the cost of the toy
is pinching you you have too expensive a
toy
and i think that's the conclusion you're
coming to that the vacation home sells
to give you the liquid cash in a paid
for house again
i would agree would it make sense at all
to downsize our current home
no um no okay not for a toy
yeah okay yeah you're gonna lower you're
gonna lower your quality of life day to
day for a
property you spend three to six weeks a
year in yeah
right yep okay that does not make sense
it's just a
it's it's a toy now i'm okay if you guys
want to roll up your sleeves and knock
this thing out with a ridiculous amount
of overtime or something in the next
three years or so
i'm not okay with you dragging along for
10 years with this crap
yeah because you shouldn't have done it
yeah you couldn't afford it
yep yep i totally agree and that's the
pinch you came on
because you pay cash for toys or you
don't buy them and
you didn't pay cash for this you over
built by a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
and uh if you had that thing sitting
there paid for you wouldn't have ever
thought about calling me and you would
never thought about selling your
personal home
none of this would have come up but the
fact that you guys over built it is what
got you
and so uh you know but here's the thing
either way is okay you're there today
i wouldn't have done it but you're there
today am i necessarily going to go oh
you're stupid if you don't sell it no
you're not
if you want to fight to keep it and you
guys live on beans and rice and you take
that budget of yours apart
and you put it back to a gazelle
intensity mindset where we're paying off
this stinking house so we can keep
because we
love this house um
i would fight to keep my lake house i
love my lake house yeah
and i would fight to keep it i mean i
would do
you know i would sacrifice like crazy if
i had backed into it wrong
in order to fix the mess and that's what
you'd be doing here i got you back but
you know you're you're holding this
thing with a pretty open hand which
makes me think you don't really want to
fight that hard to keep it i think
you're probably going to sell it
and buy something later and there's
nothing wrong with that that's exactly
right yeah
nothing wrong with it nothing wrong with
that at all that's a half a million
dollars back in your pocket
and i still wouldn't have a whole lot of
money though sitting in my checking
account i'm still going
no i know what i'm saying i mean you can
invest it in mutual funds
where you can get to it right but it's
not if you want to put a couple hundred
thousand of that money in a mutual fund
that's fine pay off your house
yeah um and uh sit there
and then keep piling some money up and
later on buy another home up there
absolutely you can do that it won't be
the one you built or build another one
up there i don't care pay cash though
for
second homes and toys but that just
makes me think though if you're gonna
build another one in two years from now
then
it's not gonna be two years oh okay no
if they're gonna do it two years they
could have paid it off in two years
right
right so the math won't do that it's
gonna be ten
ten yeah so i i'm okay you guys sit down
talk about here's
here's the thing you've been fretting
about it
and what you do need to do max is make a
decision
and let the worry go and go okay
regardless of how we got here
regardless of whatever regrets we have
about this
we're gonna buckle down and pay this
thing off in the next three years
or 40 40 months or whatever it is when
you run the math out
yeah but you're gonna do it in short
order or
it's not worth it to do that and i'm not
gonna sit here and wring my hands about
a car breaking down during that 40
months
and so i'm selling it and then let it go
yep let it go but this back and forth
sitting on the fence not having to make
the decision is more stressful
than making a painful decision pretty
much make the call
and run it out this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
family
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
john and his daughter heather are with
us hey guys how are you hey dave hey
anthony thanks for having us today
welcome we are welcome honored to have
you where do you live we live in east
hartford connecticut oh beautiful town
very nice well good to have you brother
thanks for coming all the way down here
to do your debt-free scream how much
have you paid off we've paid off
33 000 in 19 months good for you
and your range of income during that
time 88 000 during that time i was
uh salary frozen so i kind of had to
become the side hustle king
okay that works cool what do you do for
a living i'm a teacher
oh good for you what do you teach i
teach computer science and english at
buckley high school in hartford
connecticut go bulldogs
i love it wonderful very cool
so what kind of debt was your 33
thousand dollars three personal loans
two credit cards and a car that i
financed used
you are normal
[Applause]
so what happened that woke you up 19
months ago
um it was wake up time i i was shaving
one morning
and i kind of it was one of those like
newton and the apple falling on your
head kind of moments that you're having
and it was a new year's morning but what
was really happening is i was taking a
look at my life i'm like 51 years old
and um i grew up in a house with a lot
of love
my parents god rest their souls were
depression-era babies
lots of love not so much with the money
and so when i became an adult i made
all the same mistakes and then of course
went into making my own mistakes
on steroids including and i wrote some
of them down
obviously the massive credit card debt
piece then i impulse bought a half
million dollar house that i financed at
110
so that i could buy two cars i didn't
need and put renovations on the house
that it didn't
need either um which now loads me in
ungodly quantities of debt um very soon
the market crashed i lost the house
very soon after that the marriage fell
apart um
so i thought it would be a good idea to
finance my divorce with a 403 b
loan um and so uh i
eventually landed in chapter seven and
so i'm now doing the chapter seven thing
got out of the chapter seven um this is
now in my 40s and
uh get that cleared up plus of course
you know you can't cancel out the
403b loan so i have to get that paid
back got that cleared up
and started getting back into the exact
same habits
so um now fast forward to that morning
that new year's morning and you think
about you know nears what's it going to
represent
she's in middle school i got no future a
big pile of debt
i'm a dad i got one job and my one job
is to take care of her and i'm not
getting it done
and so i said okay gotta make a change
so
i'm a teacher teachers are nerds um by
nature so i read
every book out there um and i'm gonna be
totally truthful with you dave
i refuse to read dave ramsey i refused
to do it
because when i was married my wife at
the time said gee you know honey maybe
we should do the dave ramsey program and
i utterly refused
fast forward to the divorce and so we
never read it for like three months
finally after about three four months of
reading every book under the sun
including people who thought that it was
a good idea to borrow money to get rich
i went ahead and got total money
makeover read it in one night
joined fbu the next week wow
and it turned on a dime i've actually
coordinated two fpu classes since then
so thank you oh thank you that's amazing
actually can i give a shout out to my
fpu
people sure um i just my my principal at
the school
allowed me to run an fpu class for the
faculty wow
and which was unbelievable in a public
school setting and she
uh she said please run it three of the
staff members signed up and these three
women in nine weeks
paid off ten thousand five hundred
dollars in nine weeks wow
that's awesome best part of the journey
very cool very cool now on this journey
uh i'm curious what was the hardest
thing for
for you on this whole journey
saying no to her because i mean she's my
why
and and so and you're the one who
anthony you always say your wife's got
to make you cry and you did right
and so but it was saying no to no we
can't go out for
tacos every week like we used to when we
can't do all the fun trips that we used
to do and saying no to vacations and
saying no to
you know to to my girlfriend saying hey
you know we can't do this and that or i
can't you can do it but i can't and you
know all those things that i had to do
to make sure that she would be taken
care of yeah now but but it was
worth it i would do it again tomorrow
cool
cool how old how old are you heather i'm
uh i'm 15
15. so you watched your dad go through
this divorce
this bankruptcy and then took control of
his life and changed his life
very proud of him you ought to be yeah
you ought to be that's a nice a good
word
and that's a word he lived to hear right
there for sure very well done
yeah so uh what lessons do you take away
from this whole thing
um i i'm definitely gonna
follow in his footsteps when i'm older
that's good
and uh i've learned that you can always
you know
take control of your life yeah yeah so
let me give you let me give a quick
lesson
um to a young lady i'm jumping ahead of
the game your dad can break this down
later on let me give you now listen uh
date a man who's who's better than your
father
down the road whenever that whenever he
approves that
so no debt you know and man who knows
how to take control of his life that
should be one of your great lessons that
you should have down the younger version
of her father
yes not the current absolutely dead
current version
[Laughter]
very good cool well i'm proud of you
guys well done
very very well done john so you've done
fpu classes you've been through the
ringer you've you've seen the top you've
seen the bottom
what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of debt is
make the decision today to do the right
thing
today then get up tomorrow and do it
again
um work the plan because the plan works
on you
i was thinking about a frederick
douglass quote that i love
that upon which a man works works upon
him
and this plan really did change that
so so of all those things that's it the
other one is
is celebrate the wins because there's a
lot of a lot of time that you're putting
together this like train wreck of your
life
and and you want to say oh yeah i've got
this you know we got this thing done we
knocked off this credit card
you also want to occasionally remember
that you were the engineer on that train
so
you know don't repeat the mistakes but
then keep celebrating it you know
heather and i
have had charts and she colored in the
debt-free land on our fridge
and we just you know keep celebrating it
every day and coordinate
fpu don't wait till the end to be
generous because that's the most fun
you're ever going to have with money
well it holds you completely accountable
too
it does yeah very very well done i'm
curious what's next
i mean you're debt-free your daughter
watched this journey
uh well what do you do next well right
now we're working our way through baby
step
three okay um and 3b i want to get into
something a little more
stable i'm renting right now um so it's
3b um
fortunately through some circumstances
in her life she's all set she's okay for
college so we're going to do debt free
degree but i'm still going to ask you to
sign our book if you don't mind
and so we're going to do that and then
getting ready for uh getting ready for
uh baby steps four five and six and
taking care of the legacy love it
well done well done good job john
amazing
yeah absolutely incredible i'm so proud
of you very well done
and we've got a copy of rachel's book
for you of course know yourself know
your money so
you'll leave here with a whole bunch of
autographed books as a part of this trip
and
we're honored to uh to celebrate with
you and with heather
uh what a cool thing you talk about
changing your family tree that's it
that's how you do it right there i'm
looking at it more is caught
than taught so uh 33 000
paid off in 19 months making 88
john from hartford connecticut count it
down let's hear
a debt-free scream three two
one we're debt-free
[Applause]
life is good you know what dave
if if your why doesn't make you cry
like john's then you don't you need a
deeper why
well seeing him hug his daughter seeing
her hug her father
and so she's proud of him and to hear
that that will make
any father cry
[Music]
daddy i'm proud of you that's the uh
that's about the best words out there
and um
the interesting byproduct of this is
is that uh her brain is completely
reformed
absolutely there's no no possibility
of her having her doing a normal
life and going out there and creating a
mess after having
walked through this and witnessed it
firsthand like this
there's too much too much going on too
much water on the bridge she's changed
too
i mean this is how you change your
family tree right here you go first
you go first baby you go first this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today john 15 and 7
if you abide in me and my words abide in
you
ask whatever you wish and it will be
done for you
milton berle says if opportunity doesn't
knock build a door
there we go that's it drew says uh
in atlanta hi drew welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can we help
so basically i was just wondering what
the best way
to allocate my current income is in
terms of
investing you know i'm investing in a
401k
um building up my checking account
amount but i also have 550
000 in a brokerage account um as a
result of
um some good investing from uh and
inheritance over
the last about 14 years so i just want
to know if i'm doing the right things
putting my money towards the best
investment possibilities right now
okay so you inherited 550 000
i inherited about 280 um
back in 2007. so it's just built up
and you've had it invested in what
mutual funds and stocks about 75
mutual funds and for 75 and then
to rest in stocks okay and how old are
you
24. okay good um
well i don't play single stocks there's
too much risk for me
uh and i buy two things for investing
um and i don't i don't recommend people
do things that i don't
do that would be hypocritical and so i
buy real estate that i pay cash for
as an as an investment in other words
income producing real estate
and i buy mutual funds uh single stocks
more than 10 percent of your portfolio
in single stocks is too much risk for me
because i don't like losing money and
the numbers on singles
playing single stocks are not that good
but for the individual
so um if i woke up in your shoes
i would move that money into good mutual
funds with a good smart investor pro
and i wouldn't use a brokerage account
and
i think you'll end up doing better in
the long haul it'll be a lot more boring
but boring is good as far as i'm
concerned uh exciting means there's a
chance i'm about to lose some money and
i don't like exciting
so so um
you know that's what i would do with
that money and then
uh you know what do you make a year 60
000.
okay and what i would do is just go
about living my life as if that money
isn't there and it sounds like that's
what you've done so far
absolutely yes yeah and
um uh are you married do you own a home
or anything like that
no none of that okay well i would make
sure you had no debt and that you're
putting 15
of your income away for retirement and
that you're growing your career and that
you're living intentionally on a budget
uh now i would use some of that 550 out
of those mutual funds to pay cash for my
first house when you're married and get
ready to do that or when you just decide
you're going to buy a house
and there's no rush in that you're 24 if
you didn't buy a house for two or three
more years it wouldn't be that big a
deal yeah
uh and so you know let that money grow
and sit there
and you're paying cash for everything if
you can learn to live as if that money's
not there
except for the fact you pay cash for a
house later um
that's going to cause you that that's
going to take this pile of money and
make it tens of millions
yeah because you got 40 plus years for
this money to parlay
and um if you're invested in good mutual
funds and making
uh you know 10 or so that money's gonna
double about every seven years
yeah and so seven years from today when
you are uh
31 years old you'd have a million one
seven years later yeah when you're 38
you would have two million two
seven years later when you're 45 you'd
have four million
four good crisis and that's if you don't
mess with this and it just sits there in
decent mutual funds and grows at a
decent rate
this is um and so again you pull some of
that out you buy a house with it then
you take what was
going to be a house payment and invest
that you'll end up in exactly the same
place
you just you just used your own money
and now you're putting your money back
in the form of a payment uh and so and
as your career goes on
so this money literally you should be
worth
over 10 million dollars when you hit
retirement as a result of this
so very very nice gift as an inheritance
and you will be one of those
millionaires that
are a millionaire because of an
inheritance which by the way is a very
unusual thing statistically
and a wonderful gift from uh
whoever did a great job with money in
the last generation that left it to you
uh pretty cool situation man i i'm
sitting here just going over
the numbers in in my head dave like drew
if he does the right
thing today the caliber of his future is
so bright
if he just sits there at like the money
is not there and he's continuing to put
money into it
he's just adding fuel to a positive fire
for his future and guess what there's a
high probability he's going to do that
yeah and there's two
indicators of that one is he was
probably raised or influenced by whoever
did this the first time and left him the
money
yep and two we know that because he's
had this money
yeah for a while and has doubled it
already and
three he called in and asked us and
asked us yeah he
was the right way he didn't go buy a
lamborghini yep yep and which i'm
i gotta say i'm surprised you know for
20 something sitting around
i'm not surprised because he was raised
by the people that did that
and so uh you know so the rule is for
your parents then
uh your grandparents then and i'm
talking to myself as well legacy journey
book
is more caught than taught your main
inheritance is knowledge and character
and if you leave them money without
knowledge and or character
you will raise a kid in a reality show
but if you leave them character and
knowledge uh
without money they will get money yup
but if you leave them character
knowledge and money now you've changed
your family tree
yes sir and that's what's happened with
drew don't you just sense he's mature
beyond his years
absolutely that's what i'm like man if
i'm just excited for his future yeah
i think this is brilliant lila is in
san francisco hi lila welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hi how are you guys great how can we
help
so i need guidance um i have
parent plus loan for my children they're
already graduated one's out on his own
one is almost on out on their own i
don't want them to participate right now
and paying back the student loans
because i want them to
establish themselves i make 160
i have a home i owe 45 i have a car
14 000 and this student loan of 2016.
160. oh good okay and you're single i'll
take it no
yes okay so i need
go ahead oh so i need guidance i'm
thinking one
yet the government has no interest right
now and
two do i refi uh for a lower rate
like with so five um so i can start
paying this off
don't do anything with so far so far is
a dangerous operation you want to stay
completely
away from them but uh but you could look
at refinancing it
and um that'd be okay uh
and uh kelly helped me with our uh uh
yeah our company our company that we do
that with
student loan refunds splash splash
financial i'm sorry my brain just locked
up i should know this what is it
financial but here's the thing lyla
you're not going to get out refinancing
refinancing is only going to help you uh
one percent of the problem
99 of the problem is you're going to
have to live on nothing in beans and
rice and clean this mess up
a scorched earth no life yes and clean
this mess up so how much parent plus
loans is there again
it's 260. 260 000
for once for two for two
not a good decision uh they're first
generation that would be
less than an understatement oh my gosh
yes
yes i'm so sorry okay well let's do it
anyway and 14 000 on the car so we're
going to list our debts smallest to
largest
yes refinancing this is going to be
important because of the mammoth amount
it is
yeah and getting the cheapest possible
rate but
kiddo i mean you're like living on 60
000 bucks throwing 100 at this
and it's gonna take you four years
oh great but i mean you're living on
nothing
you understand i just i just took your
life and i didn't take it away
yeah you took it away when you made this
decision but i just took your life away
to get this mess cleaned up
i was the further you sacrifice the
faster you get out
yeah splash financial looked them up i
just looked them up their rates are
pretty low
wow that puts this hour of the dave
ramsey show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you